we may be down in the basement but let
me tell you so far in next level chef
some of the best food has come out the
basement what does that tell you they've
got a brilliant mentor
me
[Music]
you're gonna see it here first here is
an exclusive
behind the scenes of this next level
kitchen
all right guys here we are we're in the
top level kitchen the most amazing
cooking equipment the most beautiful
space to work in you want to be cooking
in this top level kitchen every day
there will be a different theme based
off of an amazing platform of
ingredients the platform starts at the
top where each chef has the opportunity
to have first pick at these most
phenomenal ingredients i mean look at
this morel mushrooms what cooking
competition have you ever seen that has
morel mushrooms
okay welcome to the middle level see
this is the thing about next level chef
is our competitors and judges they have
no idea what level they're gonna be
dropped off and there's so much tension
in that elevator and then they come out
and they're like okay thank goodness i'm
not in the basement our chefs here on
this middle level they're doing okay
okay they have blenders they have mixers
they have pressure cookers this is where
you're going to find some fats we have
heavy cream
we have butter we have eggs quick little
sidebar heavy cream
also used to be my dj name
you're happy to be here you're glad
maybe that you weren't on the bottom
level but you're wishing that you were
on the top and listen if it gets really
really crazy up here you have this
stockpot if it's not going well you can
hide in here something that i've never
done because my team is dominating let's
go see what's on the next level
[Music]
right welcome to the basement
this is one of the most extraordinary
basement kitchens i've ever worked in
fridges from 1970 they they shake
as they chill very little equipment
minimalistic okay check these ovens out
they're from 1974. the temperature says
350 but trust me they barely get hot
enough to cook a biscuit in there herbs
spices oils a few stocks
come over to some of the equipment uh
we've got
old-fashioned i mean i mean seriously
it's dull
it's dingy this is where we have to grab
those ingredients
now it starts off on the first floor
and then it goes down to the second
floor and by time it comes down to the
basement it's so depleted we're left
with like canned mushrooms canned
chicken have you ever seen an appetizing
chicken in a can because i haven't then
over to the stoves look at these these
things are sort of you know a little bit
rickety
sometimes they don't work
we've only got like two sinks the water
pressure is very minimal
look it's so depleted then it comes down
to the equipment we don't have like
beautiful nonstick pans um
sheet trays we got aluminium foil
this is how we boil water
and again a 1970s kettle that was
donated from my grandma by the way she
left me
get your plate from here
a bowl dress dress dress there's two
minutes to put all the food in and then
you got literally 15 seconds to get it
all the way around the lift goes up and
then you're hoping literally to get that
plate on there like that
and
sometimes the contestants are like
reaching up to the top to get their
plate on there because
the lift's gone the idea is to cook in
the basement not set it on fire yes